john wick is known as the boogeyman for
good reason
he is an unstoppable killing machine but
no man is an island
these are the weapons people and items
john wick needs to survive in his
cutthroat world
from coins symbolizing blood oaths to
his canine companions
john wick is a cold-blooded contract
killer who ends lives for a living
but the man has a solid code of ethics
and an impressive reputation
he is called the boogeyman after all
it's this
hard-earned stature as one of the
deadliest men alive that gives john a
competitive advantage
his rivals respect and fear his extreme
focus
commitment and sheer force of will
without these he's nothing
with them he's a legend in chapter two
jon finds himself pulled back into the
world of assassins by
santino d'antonio the italian crime lord
forces
jon's hand ordering him to kill
santino's sister gianna
he then puts a seven million dollar
bounty on john's head after he completes
the mission
the lack of honor in d'antonio's
behavior doesn't go unnoticed by jon
and his personal code of ethics shines
through he allows
gianna to take her own life on her own
terms
and then he goes after santino when word
of john's pursuit makes it back to the
continental
and its manager winston he has some hard
words for santino
you incinerated the priest's temple
burned it to the ground
now he's free of the market what do you
think he'll do
john is violent but he never abandons
his sense of right and wrong
even in the midst of battle santino
ignores this to his own peril
john wick is as comfortable with bladed
weapons as he is with guns
he's also well versed in a number of
martial arts
including jiu jitsu judo and karate
in john wick chapter 3 parabella we
learn that john was raised by the
institute
this ballet company is actually a front
for a secret school that trains young
assassins
his time there shows watching jon fight
is like watching a dancer at the top of
their game
his physical strength seems almost
otherworldly at times
as does his endurance no matter how many
hits he takes or the times he's shot or
stabbed
he keeps getting up you have to wonder
if the institute does more than just
train its students
could john wick actually be some sort of
enhanced super soldier
even if he doesn't have any real
superpowers jon's abilities are beyond
doubt
over the course of the john wick films
muscle cars proved to be our hero's
trademarks
from the chevelle loner he gets after
yosef tarasov
steals his boss 429 mustang to the 2011
dodge charger that helps him finish off
his beef with the tarasav family for
good
jon always travels in style these
vehicles aren't just eye candy though
jon has his work cut out for him across
the franchise
and his quest for revenge would be
exponentially harder without this
horsepower at his
disposal during the movies even when
they're getting destroyed
cars are still incredibly valuable
yosef's
theft of john's mustang might actually
be the russian criminal's true downfall
jon knows to head to a syndicate-run
chop shop managed by master mechanic
aurelio
who unfortunately for iosef is one of
jon's closest allies
aurelio does his part to make things
right by loaning john a new car
for his quest for vengeance in the world
that john wick
lives in trust is a hard thing to come
by but despite the double and triple
crosses that jon must overcome
he has still managed to find a few
people who he considers friends and
allies
as mentioned one of john's closest
friends is aurelio
they have a long history which hopefully
we'll get to see more of in future
movies
then there's marcus an equal parts rival
and ally
whose true colors shine through when he
dies trying to help his friend
there are also several smaller players
in john's orbit who he can rely on
a local cop named jimmy who is all too
familiar with john's line of work
watches over his house harry a fellow
assassin
guards ms perkins after jon stops her
assassination attempt
and jon seems friendly with the
syndicate doctor who stitches him up at
the continental in the first movie
and then again in chinatown near the
beginning of chapter 3.
john wick is full of potent symbols as
seen in the repeated use of unique
gold coins markers and tattoos the
custom minted gold
coins that every assassin carries around
bankroll the activities of
everyone from the high table down
markers are silver discs
marked with bloody thumb prints that
symbolize blood oaths
in fact it's a marker that centino
d'antonio uses to pull john wick back
into the fray at the beginning of
chapter 2.
john heads to the new york public
library in chapter 3 to retrieve
several invaluable keepsakes from a book
of russian fairy tales
hidden within the thousands of works
housed in the massive building
these items which include a rosary and a
marker prove
invaluable to his survival the rosary
grants him
entry into the institute the place where
his life as an assassin began
and the marker belongs to sophia alaswar
who owes him a crucial debt after he
saved the life of her daughter
the meaning of john's back tattoo is
revealed in chapter 3.
it is a mark of his kinship to the
people of the institute
unfortunately for john he sacrifices
that kinship for safe passage to
casablanca
the rosary he recovered from the library
is used as a brand
that destroys the tattoo leaving a mark
that says he can never come home again
despite the significant consequences of
his decision to abandon his family
it saves his life when he needs it the
most when helen died i lost
everything until that dog arrived on my
doorstep
a final gift from my wife it's easy to
forget that the john wick saga begins as
a family drama
as john's wife helen dies her spirit
lives on in daisy
a puppy that helen posthumously gifts to
john to help him remember his humanity
but when josef tarasov's goon kills
daisy
we see jon's spirit die a little when he
gets back up
he has become a force of unstoppable
rage that carries him through the rest
of the movie
at the conclusion of the first film jon
adopts a pit bull that was on a
shelter's kill list
and this act seems to bring him back to
himself a little
he doesn't give the puppy a name instead
preferring to call it
dog perhaps he's reluctant to get
attached again like he allowed himself
to do with daisy
and helen before that chapter three
introduces even more canine companions
in the form of sophia alaswar's german
shepherds
although they aren't jon's dogs they do
save his life and sophia's on multiple
occasions
john wick doesn't need guns to be deadly
but they certainly help
in john wick as he plots revenge he digs
up his personal stash from beneath his
house
but for the job that he is forced to do
for santino d'antonio
he needs a whole new arsenal in a
memorable scene from chapter 2
john visits the sommelier this artisan
of weapons helps put together a
selection of guns and knives for jon
describing each of them in terms of fine
wines
john plays along in a perfect deadpan
after centino's betrayal
and the seven million dollar bounty
placed on his head john negotiates with
the bowery king for a gun and seven
bullets
one for each million of the dollars in
his bounty
rearmed jon confronts santino and
eventually kills him on continental
grounds
which results in him being declared
excommunicado from the syndicate
by the time chapter 3 starts jon is on
the run from every assassin in the world
and his access to weapons has become
limited in one of the early fight
sequences of the third movie
jon cobbles together a working pistol
from several antique guns that functions
long enough to kill one of his many
pursuers
fortunately jon makes it back to the
continental by the end of chapter three
and together with sharon the concierge
of the famous hotel
he raids the establishment's armory for
the final shootout
right from the first movie it's clear
that jon has a very good sense of style
but it's not until chapter two that we
realize that his choice of clothes also
gives him a tactical advantage
during the job to assassinate guiana
d'antonio
he visits a man named the tailor when
the tailor
asks about what kind of lining he would
like john's answer is simple
tactical the request pays off in a great
moment in chapter 2
john pounds his chest after being shot
many times
sending dozens of bullets falling to the
ground around him
if john's outfit has any weaknesses it's
his choice of plain white dress shirts
though they look stylish the clean-cut
garments don't prevent attacks from
knives
on several occasions jon has his shirt
and body
slashed and stabbed by attackers
wielding blades
clothes may make the man but they can't
always work miracles
it's safe to say that without sofia
aleswar john wick would be a dead man
sophia is the manager of the casablanca
continental
and long ago jon helped to save her
daughter for which sophia
offered john a marker in return john
brings the marker back
many years later with a request that
sophia help him find the elder
the only person who sits above the high
table only the elder can nullify the 14
million
bounty on john's head ultimately sophia
agrees to help
but doesn't initially allow him to cash
in his marker
the move means that she will assist jon
but will still owe him a debt
and it raises questions about what
actually motivates this enigmatic woman
this becomes especially true when their
search for the elder puts sophia and her
beloved dogs in grave danger for helping
jon
how sofia and john's relationship will
play out in future movies is uncertain
but one thing is for sure it will be
exciting
john wick has a complicated relationship
with the continental the chain of hotels
run by the syndicate and the high table
spread across the world these
establishments act as neutral territory
for the criminal underworld
even though they crawl with hitmen and
assassins no business is permitted
on continental grounds even after being
declared excommunicado
jon still relies on the hotel's services
in every movie
jon goes to winston the manager of the
new york hotel for help and guidance
when jon breaks the most sacred rule by
killing santino d'antonio within the
walls of the continental
winston still gives jon a one hour grace
period before putting in the call for
excommunication
eventually jon makes his way back to the
continental at the end of chapter 3
and it's here where the franchise's most
epic battle is fought
in chapter 2 jon and his rival cassian
battle across the streets of rome
crashing into the local continental in
the process the unexpected change of
scenery puts a temporary stop to their
battle
though both warriors know their fight is
far from over later the casablanca
branch allows
jon to reach sophia her mentor bharata
and ultimately the elder
who commutes jon's death sentence it's
highly unlikely that john wick will need
to live without the aid of the
continental and future movies
given winston's betrayal at the end of
chapter 3
but it probably won't be long before jon
finds his way back into those plush
hallways
rubbing elbows with other members of the
criminal underworld
the bowery king is an outsider in the
world of john wick
whereas most assassins we've seen up to
this point are well dressed and
extremely put together
the bowery king is a street enforcer
whose network of carrier pigeons and
fake homeless people keep
information flowing around new york city
completely off the grid
when jon comes to the bowery king in
chapter 2 seeking help
it's not clear he'll get any it seems to
me that the real
question mr wick is who in this cruel
world of ours
is going to help you ultimately the
bowery king decides to help
jon he gives a hunted assassin just
enough power to take the fight back to
santino d'antonio by the end of chapter
3
the bowery king has been brutalized for
aiding jon after winston's betrayal
and john's fall from the roof of the
continental the tick-tock man recovers
john's wounded body
and delivers him to the bowery king they
both survive their trials
but barely their mutual rage and
singular desire to seek revenge on the
continental and the syndicate
results in an alliance that could be the
end of the high table
and anyone who would stand in their way
check out one of our newest videos right
here
plus even more looper videos about john
wick are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one